et bien ici à antenne 2 nous n'avons pas
voulu ram de ces réfugiés à deux chinois
ce soir nous avons voulu savoir comment
une famille cambodgienne s'était intégré
en france dominique torrès a vécu
quelques jours avec l'une d'elles
en bretagne
devant
la famille tanay à rennes depuis deux
ans le père a épousé dans un camp en
thaïlande une vague 4 en blanc
ils ont réussi enfin à parvenir en
france sans argent sans bagages
c'est pour madame tan que l'intégration
a été la plus difficile
aujourd'hui encore elle se débat avec le
français sa mort année ça mérite les
deux jumelles son corps il faut sept
caméras et l'après timide tchaï l'élève
studieux qui ne quitte guère ses livres
tandis que soria qui est né en france a
déjà toute la famille à ses pieds vous
vous voyez que le biais des plis ampli
pilleurs c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé
dément furent de mon pays bien aimé
quelles sont les difficultés que celles
des marges en france on arrive en la
première vous pas que les filles que
j'ai rencontré en français les problèmes
linguistiques bien parler français pour
contacter des gens
deuxièmement le problème quand on est
arrivé au foyer
on a rencontré ailleurs le climat
parce que à l'époque où je suis arrivé
c'était l'hiver la ligue 1 souffre de
froid parce que nous sommes venus de
chez nous nous n'avons pas assez des
vêtements chauds le troisième problème
quand on est déjà au foyer en faut
trouver au bout des censeurs sixième ou
cinquième mois le travail
je suis actuellement plâtrier du
chantier les êtres que travailler très
très dur
nous avons de ma formation que j'avais
acquise mais si on compare avec alary à
mon pays à part déploré ce soir et lesté
en france la natrue de la sécurité
matérielle mais l'image de son pays
déchiré à cette année ne quitte pas ses
pensées il retrouve souvent des amis qui
comme lui sont sans nouvelles de leurs
familles demeurées au cambodge pouvons
pas oublier notre pays c'est pour ça que
nous nous regroupons pour reparler de
nos pays
pierre bois d'origine online cromer côté
très souvent on n'arrivera pas mais
qu'avant on appelle mais c'est bien la
gentillesse des voisins est essentielle
mais le travail est également si le
patron de tonnes grant a n'avait pas que
c'était de le former sur le tas
il n'aurait à présent aucune formation
professionnelle mais surtout sans ami
qu'est la famille ta ne se serait
certainement senti isolé bien plus
longtemps
alors je mesure ça va oui ça va bien et
en mal tout seul avec des temps et je
fais peur
leur passage oh oui ça arrive assez
souvent mise à jour et à une fiction
c'est moins bon et ma fille s'est lié
d'amitié avec cette jeune fille il ne
s'arrêtera qu'avec la famille tous les
duels mais les vendeurs vacances et
pendant que pendant une dizaine de jours
dans les dernières cette personne c'est
pas mal
est-ce que cet ami qui nous apporte des
choses à vous justement à cette énorme
en est seulement au moins autant que ça
brille